Je m'appelle Ugo, j'ai 26 ans,
je viens de Grenoble mais j'ai fait mes
études à Strasbourg, capitale européenne.
J'ai étudié à Sciences Po Strasbourg
parce que j'avais pour objectif de faire
un Master en relations européennes.
Et en fait, ce qui m'a vraiment aidé,
c'est mon engagement :
mon engagement associatif d'abord.
Là, j'ai découvert le travail d'équipe,
les actions de terrain,
la convivialité aussi,
et qui s'est poursuivie à partir de 2019
dans l'engagement militant au sein
des Jeunes Démocrates
et du Mouvement Démocrate.
J'ai rejoint le Mouvement Démocrate
pour m'engager pour l'Union européenne.
Les valeurs de démocratie et d'humanisme
qu'on entend souvent
au Mouvement Démocrate se déploient
parfaitement vers l'Union européenne.
Et on l'a vu pendant la campagne de 2019,
quand l'Union européenne
est une chose si abstraite
qu'on a besoin de tout reprendre
en tant que militant.
Quand on veut
parler de l'Union européenne,
on doit d'abord parler du nombre d'États
avec par exemple des cartes géantes,
on doit parler de ce que fait
l'Union européenne au quotidien.
Et ça, c'est un combat que j'aime beaucoup
et que je retrouve d'ailleurs beaucoup
dans les députés européens,
les six députés européens.
Et j'ai la chance de travailler
pour l'un d'entre eux
qui font chaque jour
vivre ma fibre militante en faisant mieux
connaître l'Union européenne et
en agissant pour les citoyens européens,
donc les citoyens français.
Je me suis d'abord
retrouvé au MoDem dans la convivialité
et dans la solidarité associative
que j'avais vécu dans un premier temps.
En fait, les valeurs
du Mouvement Démocrate, on les apprend
d'abord par l'expérience,
avant de les apprendre dans les idées.
Mais ensuite, ces idées,
on les fait vivre et on les fait vivre.
En se retrouvant, on se rassemble.
Et c'est important
parce que quand on veut faire vivre
des propositions, nos propositions,
on doit ensemble réussir
ce qui peut être le plus utile pour tous,
avec le risque que ce ne soit pas repris.
Mais c'est ça aussi
la politique, c'est apprendre la joie
de partager des bons moments
et d'arriver à de bonnes idées, mais aussi
parfois la frustration de ne pas pouvoir
les défendre aussi loin qu'on voudrait.